the emergency services once again go
into action on borza glutes locals call
this area the Bronx the area has a high
number of unemployed migrants and
elderly much has changed here ooh I spun
in the clapper gurgaon dream up in the
past people went to the pub if they
needed something you'd say hey I need to
do some wallpapering I need three men
and afterwards we'll go for a drink and
five men would volunteer bottoms up from
spada they'd be fine none of my
girlfriends want to come here because
they say it's too dangerous at night
fairly tubs it won't compartment i've
lived here since nineteen sixty we have
no where to shop it's terrible believe
me I'm done in bins or fear do but that
isn't the only story Boise plots has to
tell black and yellow the colors of the
Borussia Dortmund soccer club are
everywhere reminders of the big moments
in the clubs and the squares history in
2012 the squad held a victory parade
here after winning both the Bundesliga
and the German Cup local people
celebrated together with millionaire
football stars
norbert dickel was there on that day he
won the German Cup with Dortmund as a
player in 1989 he shot two goals in the
final back then to the victory
celebrations took place at boors it
plots I know he roams on GC field
mentioned it when you drive around here
and see all the people gathered they
look you in the eye and start crying you
see how much they love the club and how
important these titles are for the club
in the entire region it's special this
is the beating heart of Borussia
Dortmund there's up here he afflict
that's before beer house the other part
of that beating heart is the stadium
dickel is still very much at the center
of the action here he's been the stadium
announcer for 23 years now he says that
in tough times the club has been a motor
for the entire city
I'm and to charge me for new bar towels
on average we have a crowd of more than
80,000 people it's a european record
windows keep going on over the past
three years no Club bit Real Madrid
Barcelona man unite or whoever has
reached those kind of numbers that's
what's special about Dortmund people
here totally identify with the club
that's taken it on top and the city has
grown with the success of the club new
businesses have moved into the
technological park just 20 years ago
plants and mines were shut down right
across the Ruhr Valley the area around
Bozek plots was hit hard this was once
the industrial heartland of Dortmund
just a few minutes from here Cole was
mind still was made and beer was brewed
the workers lived right here at bosnich
plants and it was also here at Bosnich
plots where they found it more than a
hundred years ago they are very own
soccer club borussia dortmund tickle
visits the Church of the Holy Trinity on
borz it plots it was members of this
church who founded the Borussia ball
sports club in 1909 an exhibition
entitled church soccer and trust in God
looks back at that time many people here
will tell you that for Dortmund football
is much more than a sport he was fine
reduced the best fallen huda industrial
site was what many workers here
identified with 17,000 jobs were lost
here comforted that's not something you
forget overnight a huge part of the
industrial area of Dortmund was lost the
soccer club has helped to give something
of that identity back to the people
identity a sea of black and yellow on
match days there are only two colors in
Dortmund
the stadium announcer is in his element
he conducts the masses and welcomes the
team rituals that the diehard fans live
for weather here in the stadium or back
at boors it plots not everyone here can
afford a ticket for the stadium many
come to watch the match together at this
local fan club people come from near and
far to cheer on their team but if until
it's a great mix of people from all
backgrounds and walks of life football
is what brings them all together it's a
good feeling boyer don't have been a
dortmund fan since 1973 believe that's
before me domin is our life true love is
only Dortmund the club could certainly
use a little love right now things are
not going well in the Bundesliga but
Bozek plots is no stranger to tough
times people here are holding out until
the time comes to celebrate another
victory for Dortmund